a lot of what we do with laplace
transforms taking them and taking their
inverse it's a lot of pattern matching
and it shouldn't just be a mechanical
thing and that's why i've gone through
the exercise of showing you why they
work but in order to just kind of make
sure we don't get confused i think it
might be useful to review a little bit
of everything that we've learned so far
so in the last video we saw
that the laplace transform let me just
write something a little the laplace
transform of f of t
let me just get some notation down we
can write that as big capital f of s and
i've told you that before
and so given that in the last video i
showed you that if we had to deal with a
a the unit step function so if i said
the laplace transform of the unit step
function that becomes one at some value
c
times some shifted function
f of t minus e
in the last video we saw that this is
just equal to
e
to the minus c s
times the laplace transform of just this
function right there so times the f of s
times
f of s
and it's really important not to get
this confused with another laplace
transform property or rule or whatever
you want to call it that we figured out
i think it was one of the videos that i
made last year but if you're just
following these in order i think it's
three or four videos ago
and that one
told us that the laplace transform
the laplace transform of e
to the a t
times
f of t
that this is equal to
you instead of and i want to make this
distinction very clear here we shifted
the f of t and we got just a kind of a
regular f of s
in this situation when we multiply it
times the e to the positive a t
we end up shifting
we end up shifting the actual transform
so this becomes f of
s
minus a
and these two rules or or properties or
whatever you want to call them they're
very easy to confuse with each other so
we're going to do a couple of examples
that we're going to have to figure out
which one of these two apply and let's
write all the other stuff that we
learned as well the very first thing we
learned was that the laplace transform
of 1
was equal to 1 over s we know that that
that's a pretty straightforward one easy
to prove to yourself and more generally
we learned that the laplace transform of
t to the n
where n is a positive integer
and as a positive integer it equaled n
factorial over
n factorial over s
to the n plus one and then we had our
trig functions
that we've gone over let me do this in a
different color
let me do it i'll do it right here the
laplace transform
of sine
of a t
is equal to
a
over s squared plus a squared and the
laplace transform of the cosine
of a t
is equal to s
over s squared plus a squared and you'll
be amazed by how far we can go with just
what i've written here in future videos
we're gonna we're gonna
broaden our toolkit even further but
just these right here you can already do
a whole set of laplace transforms and
inverse laplace transforms so let's try
to do a few so let's say i were to give
you the laplace transform this is just
the hard part i think you know how to
solve a differential equation if you
know how to take the laplace transforms
and go back and forth the hard part is
just recognizing or inverting your
laplace transform so let's say we had
the laplace transform
of some function f of s
let's say it's 3
factorial
over
s minus 2
to the fourth
now your pattern matching or your
pattern recognition part of your brain
should immediately say look i have a
laplace transform of something that has
a factorial in it and it's over an
exponent this must be something related
to this
thing right here right if i just had the
laplace transform let me write that down
the laplace transform of
the laplace transform you see a three
factorial and a fourth power so it looks
like n is equal to three
so if you write the laplace transform of
t to the three
this rule that we showed right here this
means that
it would be equal to
3 factorial
over
s to the fourth
now this thing isn't exactly this thing
they're not quite the same thing and
just you know i'm doing this to instruct
you but i find these when i'm actually
doing them on an exam i remember when i
did them in in when i first learned this
i would actually go through this step
because i was you know you definitely
don't want to make a careless mistake
and you definitely want to kind of make
sure you have a good handle on what
you're doing just like okay it's
something related to this but what's the
difference between
this expression right here and the
expression that we're trying to take the
inverse laplace transform of and this
one here
well we've shifted our s
right if we call if we call this if we
call this expression right here f of s
we call this expression right here
f of s then what's this expression this
expression right here is f of s minus
two
right that expression is f of s minus
two so what are we dealing with here
so you see here you have a shifted
f s right so in this case a
a would be equal to two
so this is the laplace transform of e to
the a t times our f of t
so this is the laplace transform so let
me write this down this is the laplace
transform
of e to the and what's a a is what we
shifted by
right it's what we shifted by minus a so
you have a positive there so e to the 2t
times r times the actual function if
this was just an f of s what would f of
t be well we figure that is t to the 3
t to the third power
so this the laplace transform of this
is equal to that or we could write that
the inverse
laplace transform
of 3
factorial
over
s minus 2 to the fourth is equal to e to
the 2t
times t to the third
now if if that
seemed confusing to you you can kind of
go forward you can kind of let's let's
let's apply this let's go the other
direction and maybe this will make it a
little bit clearer for you so let's go
from this direction if i had to take the
laplace transform of this thing i'd say
okay well the laplace transform of t to
the third is easy the laplace transform
of t to the third
i'll do here i think yeah the tool isn't
working right there properly let me
scroll up a little bit
so i could write it right here
so if i wanted to figure out the laplace
transform
of e to the 2t times t to the third
i'll say well you know this e to the 2t
i remember that it shifts something so
if i know that the laplace transform
of t to the third
this is an easy one it's equal to three
factorial
over
s to the fourth that's three plus one
then it the laplace transform of e to
the 2t times t to the third is going to
be this
shifted this is equal to
f of s
then this is going to be f of
s minus 2
f of s minus 2. so what's f of s minus
two it's going to be equal to three
factorial
over
s minus two to the fourth i think you're
already getting appreciation that the
hardest thing about these laplace
transform problems are really kind of
all of these shifts and kind of
recognizing the patterns and recognizing
what's your a and what's your c and
being very careful about it so you don't
make a a careless mistake and i think
doing a lot of examples probably helps a
lot so let's let's do a couple of more
to kind of make sure things things
really get
get hammered home in your brain
so let's try
this one right here this looks like a
little bit more complicated
they give us that the laplace transform
of some function
is equal to 2 times s minus
one
times e to the minus two s
all of that
over s squared
minus two s
plus 2. now this looks very daunting how
do you do this i have an e here i have
something shifted here i have this
polynomial on the in the in the
denominator here what can i do with this
so the first thing i when i look at
these polynomials in the denominator i
say can i factor it somehow and i can i
factor it some out fairly simply in in
actually in the exams that you'll you'll
find in differential equation class
they'll never give you something that's
factorable into you know these weird
numbers it'll allow it tends to be
integers when you see okay what two
numbers they have to be positive
when you give their product you get two
and then when you add them you get
negative two you can't have or they
could both be negative but there's no
two easy numbers not one and two none of
those work
so if you can't factor this out right
the next idea is maybe you can complete
the square and maybe this will match one
of the cosine of the sine formula so how
can we complete the square on this
denominator
well this can be rewritten as
this could be rewritten as let me
rewrite this as
s squared minus 2s
and i'm going to put a plus 2 out here
and this hopefully if and you can watch
my i have a bunch of videos on
completing the square if all of this
looks foreign to you and to complete the
square we just want to turn this into a
perfect square so to turn this into a
perfect square
s let's see so something when i add to
itself twice becomes minus 2 and so that
when i square it
was and what when i add it to itself
twice it becomes minus 2 it's minus one
and when i square it it'll become plus
one
plus one
i can't just add plus one arbitrarily to
some expression i have to make it
neutral so let me subtract one i haven't
changed this i added one and i
subtracted one a little bit of a primer
on completing the square but by doing
this i now can call this expression
right here
i can now say that this thing is s
minus 1
squared and then this stuff out here
this out here is two minus one this is
just plus one so i can rewrite my entire
expression now
as
two times s minus one times e to the
minus two s
make sure i'm not clipping off at the
top e to the minus 2s
all of that over
s minus 1 squared
plus 1.
so a couple of interesting things are
are are starting to
seem to be seem to be happening here so
if i just had let's just do a couple of
test laplace transforms if i take the
laplace transform
of cosine of t
we know that this is equal to
s
over s squared plus one
which this kind of looks like if this
was an s and this was an s squared plus
one
if this was f of s
then what is this
well let's ignore this guy right here
for a little bit
so what is we know we actually from the
last video we saw well what if we took
the laplace transform
the laplace transform of e
to the i'll call it one t but let's say
e to the let's write e is the what to
the one t
times cosine of t
well then this will just shift
this laplace transform by one will shift
it by one to the right so this will just
wherever you see an s you would put an s
minus a one so this will be equal to
s minus one
over
s minus one squared plus one
we're getting close we're getting close
we now figured out this part
right here
now in the previous video i think it was
two videos ago
or maybe it was the last video i forget
memory fails me
i showed you that if the if you have the
laplace transform
of the unit
the unit step function of t
times some f of t shifted
by some value of c
then that this is equal to
this is equal to e
to the
minus
c s
times
f of s
right okay so if we know and this can
get very confusing
this can get very confusing so i want to
be very careful here let's let's ignore
all of this i call this f of s before
but i'm going to
backtrack a little bit and let's say
just ignore this because i want to i'm
going to redefine our f of s let's just
ignore that for a second let's define
our new f of t to be this let's say that
that is f of t let's say f of t
is equal to e to the t cosine of t
then if you take the laplace transform
of that
that means that f of s
f of s is equal to
s minus 1
over
s minus 1 squared
plus 1. nothing fancy there i just
defined our f of t is this and then our
f of s is that right
now
we have a situation here this expression
let's ignore the two here the two we is
just kind of a scaling factor we can
this expression right here we can
rewrite
as that expression is equal if this is
our f of s
this expression right here is equal to 2
times our f of s
times e to the minus
2s or let me just write let me switch
the order just so we make make it make
it look right 2 times e to the minus 2s
times
f of s
well that looks just like this
if r 2 was equal to our c
right if our 2 was equal to rc so what
does that tell us that tells us that the
inverse laplace transform if we take the
inverse laplace transform and let's
ignore the two well this is well we
could just write
let's let's take the inverse laplace
transform of the whole thing
the inverse laplace transform of this
thing
is going to be equal to we can just
write the 2 there as a scaling factor
2 there times this thing
times the unit step function
the unit step function what's our c
if you just can just pattern match you
have a two here you have a c a minus c
minus two so c is two the unit step
function is zero until it gets to two
times t
or or of t so you know then it becomes
one after t is equal to two
times our function
shifted
by
two
shifted by two so this is our inverse
laplace transform
now what was our function
our function was this thing
right here
so our inverse laplace transform of that
thing that i had written
is this thing and f of t
f of t is equal to e to the t
cosine of t
then our inverse let me write all of
this down let me write kind of our big
result we find we were established that
the inverse laplace transform
of that big thing that i had written
before 2 times s minus 1
times e to the minus 2
sorry e to the minus 2 s
wouldn't have a t there if we
over
s squared minus two s plus two
is equal to this thing where f of t is
this or we could just rewrite this as
two
two times the unit step function
starting at 2
or that's when it becomes non-zero of t
times f of t minus 2 f of t minus 2 is
this with t being replaced by t minus 2.
i'll do another color just to ease the
monotony so it would be e
to the t
minus 2
cosine
of
t
minus 2. now you might be thinking sal
you know he must have taken all these
baby steps with this problem because
he's trying to explain it to me but i'm
taking baby steps with this problem so
that i myself don't get confused and i
think it's
it's essential that you do take these
baby steps and let's just think about
what baby steps we took and i really
want to review this this is actually a
surprisingly good problem i didn't
realize it when i first decided to do it
we saw this thing we we wanted to get
this denominator into some form that is
vaguely vaguely
useful to us so i completed the square
there and then we rewrote our our
laplace transform this our f of s like
this and then we use a little pattern
recognition we said look if i take the
laplace transform of cosine of t
i'd get s over s squared plus one
but this is an s over s squared plus one
it's s minus one over s minus 1 squared
plus 1. so we said oh well that means
that we we're multiplying our original
time domain function we're multiplying
our f of t
times e to the 1t
e to the 1t and that's what we got there
right so the laplace transform of e to
the t cosine of t became s minus 1 over
s minus 1 squared plus 1.
and then we had this e to the minus 2s
this entire time and that's where we
said hey if we have e minus e to the
minus 2s
in our laplace transform then when you
take the inverse laplace transform it
must be
the step function times the shifted
version of that function that's why i
was very careful and you had this 2
hanging out the whole time and i could
have used it any time but the the just
simple constants just scale so you can
just you know two times
a function is equal to two times the
laplace transform of that function and
vice versa so the twos are very easy to
deal with so i kind of ignored that most
of the time but that's why i was very
careful i i redefined f of t to be this
f of s to be this and said g if i have
if f of s is this
and if i'm multiplying it times e to the
minus 2
then what i'm essentially doing i'm i'm
fitting this pattern right here and so
the answer to my problem is going to be
the unit step function i just throw the
2 out there the 2 times the unit step
function
times my f of t shifted by c and now we
established this was our f of t so we
just shifted it by
c we shifted it by two and we got our
final answer so this is about as hard up
to this point as you'll see a an inverse
laplace transform problem so hopefully
you found that pretty interesting